[Music]
ladies and gentlemen hello welcome to
simulation your host town Sock'em today
we have the pleasure of sitting down
with dr. alex possession vic hello hi
thank you for coming on the show thanks
for inviting me really appreciate it
my pleasure we are mutual friends with
my increment who linked us up she's
wonderful and she's on the show and now
we've had a couple phone calls a really
good phone calls and so I'm excited to
have this in-person conversation this is
great go little fire away a little bit
of background on Alex
he has been 24 years now professing an
associate dean of Graduate Studies at
Santa Clara University that is down near
the San Jose area he's also a PhD in
electrical engineering from Santa Clara
University and also he is the author of
truth beauty and the limits of knowledge
so we have truth beauty and the limits
of knowledge we have we in your the
course that you're professing about
science and religion we have a lot to
unpack that's fun mm-hmm so maybe I have
to ask us first because anyone that's
been teaching even for like five years
or ten years I always ask what have been
some of your favorite takeaways from the
process of enriching young minds it's
unpredictable it's never the same
however many times you teach that class
it's a it's it not just that one but
that one in particular it's it's it's an
interactive thing and and they ask you
questions sometimes you've never thought
of they put you in a spot you put them
on the spot as well and at the end they
they write essays which is really
illuminating because sometimes they're
very personal about these things and and
you see the kinds of issues that people
have particularly those who care about
religion
and have had mixed experiences so
sometimes they they start out in a
traditional way then they get
disillusioned then they look at it from
another perspective because they're now
all science and engineering students so
yeah it's it's it's it's never been
boring I have to say it's been more than
ten years now that I've been teaching
that particular class I like how you
bring up that there's the interplay
between you asking them and putting them
on their BOTS and then then being like
well professor I have a question and
then oh yeah and then all of a sudden
you're like dang I haven't heard of that
one yet and that they're actually very
up-to-date I mean they have their their
their phones their laptops they're so
something happened that morning they're
usually a step ahead of me yeah and then
I really enjoyed how you brought up that
the perspective shift we've we've talked
about on the show expanding the mind to
new dimensions or some people call them
a view quakes so when your mind gets
shifted around and you're open to your
mind being shifted around like that it
is so fascinating all of a sudden one
moment you might be like ah nothing
about religion is good and then the next
moment somebody will teach you something
about religion and you're like wait
that's actually interesting
mm-hm and then you so it's interesting
how you can go from no interest to some
interest a lot of interest to life
changing to maybe back to not as
interested its social strange yeah well
usually as you accumulate knowledge I
think your understanding of something
becomes more sophisticated you never
quite get back to the same point where
you were yeah
simply because there there are different
levels of religion there's that basic
ritualistic part that many people engage
in where you don't think very much about
what's behind it and that's something
that you can easily grow out of over
time if that's all there is because
there are no questions there and there
are some fundamental issues that you
have to resolve particularly if you're
in the sciences and in engineering
because there comes a point where you
you could legitimately ask the question
okay can I believe this and
same time be consistent with what my
profession is and that's really what
what drove the development of that
course so that's a question I asked
myself can I believe what I would like
to believe and be intellectually honest
given what I know
can we attack this now since we're here
let's let's go for it so what was this
thesis of yours that it was like I
believe in some scientific objective
truth but then if I believe in religion
it somehow cancels that out but then I
can believe on them together yeah I
think it's it's a common perspective
that science and religion are somehow in
conflict and that doesn't necessarily
have to be the case if you look at
science for what it is today and we tend
to think in Newtonian terms because
that's intuitive and we've learned it
that way in school it's been that way
for almost 300 years where you know
apples fall down and never go upwards
and the second first and second and
third law are all obvious but physics
really hasn't been that way for a
hundred years if you look at quantum
mechanics if you look at string theory
all of these strange new discoveries the
the physical reality is sometimes
stranger than the reality you you hear
from religious texts and the fact the
fact that it's that way kind of opens up
your mind what what what is that reality
that we're talking about it's not like
this one's intuitive obvious and this
one is weird and and they're both
strange and then you have to ask
yourself okay if that's what the reality
is really like what should my position
be and that's where the limits of
knowledge come into play because if
science acknowledges that such limits
exist in the natural world that's a
great starting point for a conversation
because limits of knowledge opened the
door to the existence of a mystery
mm-hmm and if we agree on that then I
think it's a very different and more
constructive converse
okay so we have lots of people that
think that we're going to analyze the
crap out of existence with science and
then we have the put possibility to try
and say okay we'll analyze as much of it
as possible but let's leave a little bit
open to the possibility that there are
things like string theory and clinics if
that are actually more complex at times
then even religion is and and maybe that
that opening up that door actually
leaves more ability to have conversation
about things that are maybe real or
things that are maybe not in the three
dimensional reality that we see so I do
see how that actually helps a lot
it does help I think it helped me for
sure because the moment you opened the
door to a mystery the question is not
whether or not it exists but what is it
like and we can disagree on that you
could have people who are religious who
say that it's a benevolent beautiful
mystery that cares about you or you
could say it's a cold dark disinterested
one but it's there mmm-hmm and I think
that's the very first step we need to
make because there are many many people
who would deny that David well they'll
say exactly what you did we'll analyze
everything it's like counting you know
you can count ad infinitum and every
time you do you're gonna miss everything
in between two integers there's a lot
there yeah exactly
so there's no end to research and
discovery but that doesn't mean you're
gonna cover everything and we're
learning that because we have now come
to a point where we're we're tackling
systems that are not that simple anymore
we started out with that paradox one
more time the amount of numbers between
zero and one mmm is infinity and then
the amount of numbers between zero and
infinity is also infinity oh don't get
me started on that one but yeah there's
different kinds of infinity
so yeah yeah exactly and so Ron I want
to loop Iran into this cuz I think wait
wait I have I have the point first let
me get the point out first
Alex mentions how whatever exists
outside of the 3d reality we can either
say that it's it's dark and it's
nothingness and like it's totally
nothingness and then other people can
make such a mystical and like hypothesis
around something what it could be what
are you well I'm not the latter and
there is it isn't dark outside of this
3d reality is it's quite remarkable
there's there's it's sometimes I think
it's the secret sometimes I can't you
know I don't want to discuss it too much
but there's there's clues there's
symbols it's it's it's like I'm the star
of my own science fiction movie when you
think beyond the 3d reality and people
will think you're crazy but it's it's
helped me if anyway pursue the things
that I want to do and not be enslaved
quote-unquote or caught in the matrix
you know I have to bend time and space
and it's it's all in my it's all in my
head
so that's where I feel there is there is
much beyond this 3d reality and life is
extremely short these bodies are meat
puppets here briefly and the truth lies
beyond the dimensions beyond 3d that's
the keyword truth which I think all the
great physicists have said that we
cannot know nature or is law its laws as
they really are we can only answer
certain questions that we pose ourselves
yeah that's not the same thing
yeah so if if that that and that's a
fundamental metaphysical restriction you
will exactly so that's that that's part
of what I refer to as the mystery the
fundamental question that you can ask in
science which is not one that science
can answer is why are the laws the way
they are
because if there
even the tiniest bit different then you
and I are not talking here we don't
exist as such I mean we really exist on
the edge of a razor yeah if the mass of
an electron and a proton if that ratio
changes at the 30th decimal place
everything falls apart
it's that finely tuned so if you're
talking about the nature of that mystery
or truth or whatever then you have to
build it into that question as well so
why are the laws exactly that way when
they could be something totally
different not conducive to life or
intelligence at all I love the example
that you give which is we have we've
evolved on this rock and then we pose
the questions that we think are we
framed the world through the question
and then we analyze it to come up a
solution but that's we're limited to our
perception we're limited to the way that
we structure these questions so to
actually know what the laws of nature
are around us yeah we'll never be exact
yeah it'll be very difficult to figure
that out and then piggybacking off of
what Ron said Ron really you know he's
looking for these feelings these
connectivity spiritually to the outside
of the 3d world these clues all these
different things do you also feel some
of that yeah that's actually where I
think religion and art and beauty come
into play they are the intangible
part of that reality because if you
could put everything in in words then
that would be it that there would be no
need for other types of art beyond
literature and you know New York Times
would be your only source of information
that's not true part of being human is
to go beyond that and it's I always kind
of cringe when I hear these these
reductionist theories that it's all
about matter it matters involved of
course it is but what makes you you is
it the matter that makes you because
there isn't a single molecule in you
that was there five years ago so why are
you still you
you tell me mmm-hmm what makes you you
clearly not just your material makeup
it's the way it's organized and that's
the difference between matter and
information so I always give an analogy
with a chess game so you play a chess
game and then you come and knock down
the pieces what happened to the game is
it gone the game itself isn't gone the
pieces are gone you can replay it with
other pieces or you can replay it in
your head so information does not follow
the same rules as matter does and
clearly it is play it plays a role in
defining who we are and and everything
else I mean physicists today are
speculating that information is in some
way superior to matter yeah I mean
there's that famous phrase it from bit
it from bit yes which means essentially
matter from information and matter is
where it gets played out but it's not
the essence of of not just what we are
but what the physical world is so it
seems like then the next step of
evolution then is information there's an
attack on information we can't lose
sight that there's a dark villain among
us when you mentioned art and the
importance of that understanding I also
believe you know that you can't just
come right out and say these things you
have to encode it in a poem or a song
and get people to think and just apply
it I'm inspired by the music that I grew
up with the lyrics that I listen to and
but there's also a there's an attack on
that creative process in my opinion you
know I you know in my science fiction
movie that I was talking about so art is
vital yeah well Ron also brings up a
really crucial point which is that we
have to ink
the the information to get it to the
masses and it's very interesting we have
a lot of other close friends that are
doing similar things but to be very
careful with the way that the
information is presented a lot of people
say like oh I had an incredible time on
LSD or I went to I did this incredible
experience and then people will
literally tell them that like okay
that's scary to me I don't that's not
interesting to me and then all of a
sudden that information will degrade
that experience that feeling that
emotion will degrade that aliveness for
them so it's really important to package
this information for example this
enlightenment maybe about about quantum
computing what if you could turn quantum
computing into a song into a mainstream
pop culture song hey you know so so then
so these kind of ways to encode
information is something that you know
we care about a lot that's you know on
this show you're talking about science
and religion and we're trying to unpack
this in as relatable explain like I'm
five explain like I'm 10 or 15 will you
way possible so okay let's let's touch
on this since we're on the subject the
chaos and order mm-hmm we have let's why
don't you go ahead and tell us about
what the what you've been doing in that
chaos is a word that's often
misinterpreted because the implication
is that it's complete disorder in fact
the modern understanding of chaos and
system theory is that it's hidden order
it looks random by many standards but if
you frame the data in a certain way all
of a sudden you see some kind of meta
order appear so chaos is really a mix of
order and disorder on the surface and on
the surface only it looks random and and
it seems to be one of the key mechanisms
in nature for the emergence of
complexity so this whole idea and this
this is one of the unites
about this debate between pro Darwinists
and and those who are more religiously
minded about whether something like
evolution that has a random component
can actually have some sort of direction
well randomness is really not the enemy
randomness is what jolts you a little
bit so that you get out of your local
equilibrium and explore a little further
that's what we're discovering in in the
world of complex systems so chaos is
really not a bad word anymore it was for
a couple thousand years but nowadays
it's it's a fascinating phenomena let
the butterfly effect I mean it sounds
like an exaggeration but literally if
you look at it mathematically it's a
system that's infinitely sensitive
mm-hmm to its initial condition so you
changed them at whatever decimal you
like eventually there will be some
macroscopic effect yeah so the whole
story with the butterfly effect was a
remark that Edward Lawrence made he was
the guy who discovered the phenomena and
he said that the movements of a
butterfly's wings somewhere in the
Amazon could affect the long-term
pattern of weather in China and
technically speaking he was correct
because it is a chaotic system and if
you change something at whatever decimal
point eventually you'll see the
difference I like to make this relatable
example for that as well which is if you
smile and someone when you're walking
down the street or doing something in
the service or retail industry and they
notice your smile and they smile back
they will then affect the next person
and then that person will affect the
next person there's this whole all of a
sudden that person's calling their
family in Norway and then they're
happier the person in Norway's happier
than averse and Norway's interacting
with other people on the streets so
there's an insane connectivity across
all of it for even humans as well true
however there we don't have a model so
we cannot technically speak of chaos we
don't we don't have a knife a clue how
to model all that but you have a
similar conclusion coming from a very
different angle from quantum mechanics
the so called EPR paradox which Einstein
posed back in the 30s which essentially
tells you that particles any two
particles that ever interacted
throughout the history of the universe
are somehow entangled they could be in
different galaxies right now and if
they're in that state of entanglement
you measure one in one galaxy the other
one in the other galaxy is immediately
its opposite Einstein couldn't buy that
he was actually philosophically opposed
to that interpretation of quantum
mechanics so he spent the better part of
his last 20 years trying to undermine it
and this paradox was supposed to do the
trick and it so happens that he was
wrong it took another 20-some years to
construct an experiment that would test
this and Einstein was wrong that that
what he called spooky action at a
distance actually exists mm-hmm so it's
uh that's why they call quantum
mechanics unknown local theory which is
another fancy way of saying what you
just said that things are connected in
ways that we don't necessarily
understand and if that's really the case
then the the scope of what we can know
is inherently limited you don't even
know what you're looking for
because if if there's a global
phenomenon that depends on everything
that's out there and we only see a slice
of it how could you possibly see
anything but randomness there I mean
what kind of rule or pattern or would
you expect to see and I find that
phenomenon fascinating because it's it's
been beaten to death it's been tested
and tested to the point where they now
some ten years ago looked at two
particles that were 11 kilometers away
which is a galactic distance for two
particles and the effect was still
they're not diminished in any way so we
can safely say that such a thing exists
what it means we don't quite know but
we've kind of scratched the surface on
that and what we see is much stranger
than than what you hear from you know
some theologians particularly those who
are a little more sophisticated
does the
quantum entanglement across parts of the
universe does that have something to do
with symmetry and asymmetry in a very
indirect way but symmetry has always
been a tool that scientists have used to
break ties essentially if you don't have
an intuitive feel as to what's going on
and you have multiple candidates for a
theory you're often gonna go with the
one that's the most aesthetically
pleasing and we like symmetry yeah so a
lot of modern science and modern physics
in particular was based on symmetries
which were mathematical largely because
we thought that's cool and then we found
things we didn't bargain for just
following that lead so the beauty as a
criterion in science has been remarkably
effective we have no explanation for why
because it's a subjective thing we like
symmetry possibly for biological reasons
because you know living organisms tend
to be more symmetric than nonliving
matter so it matters to you whether you
you know to our ancestors it did whether
it's a rock or it's a bear you know so
we're kind of pre conditioned to like it
but the fact that this could now be the
key to unlocking some secrets of the
universe that that's much more than we
ever bargained for and why that's the
case is quite I don't have an answer to
it but a fascinates me so understanding
symmetry and asymmetry could be key to
understanding our universe it turns out
that it's been very helpful because if
you look at modern particle physics and
even before that when Mendeleev came up
with a periodic system about half of the
elements were known at the time and he
just kind of filled in the blanks and
said this it there must be something
there and lo and behold there was so the
same thing happened with the Omega minus
particle which is thats a long story but
if they found a bunch of particles which
when you graph them in a certain way
fill out a region very symmetrically and
then there's one missing at the bottom
and murray gell-mann who
covered that phenomenon said well there
must be something there and a couple of
years later they looked for it they
found that famous Omega - so symmetry
has been really good to us but if it was
just symmetry again we wouldn't be here
because if there was perfect symmetry
between matter and antimatter that would
all cancel each other out at the very
beginning of the universe and in fact we
are here because there was a slight
slight excess of matter over antimatter
one in the million let's say under those
conditions and so symmetry breaking and
symmetry together yeah are the key about
one of the keys who knows what the real
key is but for us and our discovery yes
the slow genetic evolutions as well our
breaks and symmetry um you could say so
yes increases in chaos uh I'm not sure I
would put it that way there's a term
that scientists use it called frozen
accidents where in principle you could
have many different like if you put a
pencil on the desk upside down
theoretically could fall anywhere wait
the people are likelihood as well same
thing but a pencil is even more put it
on its tip and here we go anyway so the
laws themselves allow all sorts of
outcomes but if you actually do that
it'll fall in one particular direction
and after that that'll determine the
evolution of whatever the system is for
the foreseeable future
so but it's an accident in fact it
didn't have to happen that way
evolution is kind of like that - there
are lots of things that didn't have to
happen but did and influenced the way
different species evolved but that's the
random piece to it but then there is a
lawful piece because information is
transmitted quite lawfully from one
generation to the next with a little bit
of distortion with mutations and things
like that but there is order mixed with
that kind of disorder and the fact that
something like us comes out at the tail
end of all that is fascinating
think about it through us the universe
is aware of itself yes which isn't
shabby at all so
it's absolutely amazing yeah and that we
can state as a fact yes oh and what
happens after that remains to be seen
mm-hmm
hopefully civilization thrives yeah yes
yeah these days you you have your doubts
but I'm sure they did in the past as
well oh yeah I believe this is part of
the learning process do you know to be
positive and but I hear you the doubt
that we would have well the problem is
that I think and this is I don't want to
rant against social media but mmm from
the Enlightenment to this day there was
a kind of consensus as to what
constitutes truth mm-hmm and what
standards have to be met before you can
call something a fact and then because
social media allowed I mean they have
their good sides but because they
allowed people to kind of connect with
those who are like-minded they now have
the opportunity to to ignore those
standards and to live in a reality of
their own which is not an objective one
so it's almost an undoing of the
Enlightenment if you will confirmation
bias
yes but the fact of the matter is a two
and two are still four and that the laws
of nature as we know them are still
pretty solid and that's not up for
debate
yeah what we can debate our
interpretations of certain scientific
things not not all facts are debatable
and and yeah and this started before I
mean this started with the postmodern
movement correct when they started
relativizing math as a human construct
there is a human element to math but two
and two are still four yeah yeah so
let's not push that in gravity yeah time
twenty meters per second squared on the
surface of the earth
yeah and malt molecule molecular
composition of water is objectively true
we know it is you know there's no post
modernist discussion about those things
but then all these different
interpretations of subjective realities
of course are yeah I'm sure so
mathematics is truly the universal
language that in my opinion that's a
slippery slope let me tell you why
because mathematics generally a
placed as its practice today is based on
axioms and axioms can be anything at all
those are things we choose and to the
Greeks many centuries ago axioms were
self-evident things but not today today
they can be anything at all yeah that is
just taken to be true and then we go
from there
that's the human element in math so we
do get to pick our axioms and and and
once we do because you have multiple
geometries you have Euclidian geometry
which you learned in school but then you
have non Euclidean geometry which has a
different axiom and it's it's totally
unlike that so there are many maths I
stand corrected the idea of first
principles thinking in general with
axioms axiomatic thinking that style of
thinking has been lost over the last 500
years due to this explosion especially
in the last ten years of technology and
social media now there's no axiomatic
first principles thinking and now it's
just everything that is said online is
just taken like its truth yeah and so
this is like you said in the past it
used to be something sacred something
that yeah it's not anymore and to some
people it is but a lot it isn't yeah and
that's that's really the battle of the
21st century you know we'll facts
survive as such because once you get
into these kinds of fictional constructs
than anything goes and a mark of an
inconsistent mathematical system is that
everything is a theorem everything is
true in other words so one way to prove
consistency in mathematics is to find at
least one statement that isn't true in
that system then then you're going
somewhere so to kind of get back to
those fundamental prayer and that's a
matter of Education really yeah it is uh
and it parent yeah as number one yeah
yeah but it's education not just
formally through schools but I think
also I think the media have
yeah responsibility yeah not just to
make money but to to increase
enlightenment if you will exactly if you
maybe the second that you start
propagating information on the Internet
you're putting that into the eyes of
children yeah and when you're putting
into the eyes of children and then
you're running advertisements that are
monetizing your company and paying for
them but then some of the ads are
malevolent ads and some of the content
again we don't have a philosophical or
an ethical responsibility baked into us
to want to bring forth goodness through
social media we bring forth whatever we
want exactly and the prerequisite for a
democracy is an educated reasonably
educated population that's exactly and
it's getting more and more so because
you're gonna be voting about things that
are technical yeah one of these days
there will be things like related to
nanotechnology to cloning to God knows
what else we're already talking about
data security and things like that and
those are things that are hard to
understand yeah even if you are educated
I mean it's hard yes and explaining it
on a level where the average person can
at least get a sense of it will help
otherwise the whole paradigm is is
vulnerable because then you you have an
uninformed population that's supposed to
vote on issues that are crucial and they
won't even know what hit them
until until later so yeah that it's
really important it's a major point yeah
we have so many of these exploding
technologies that are coming into our
world and we have people that are just
even educated people struggle with
understanding these things well educated
people do because well-educated people
sometimes go vertically deep into one
thing and then you pull the blockchain
token out and they're like what's that
and then you pull the quantum computing
token ow and they're like what's that
and then you pull the cloning and
genetic engineering tokens out and
they're like what's that and then all of
a sudden we have to vote on these things
we have to talk about these things we
have to make these things are relatable
for people so that
this is this is where that's a major
point and I really want to put a big
flag there yeah Ron wink because if we
you know I really like to unpack that
because what do we do what do you think
we should do moving forward to ensure
that people get that education that's
needed in order to have these
conversations and vote and but for one
thing I think education cannot be one
dimension you said dive down deep into
one thing that's necessary but not
sufficient if you do that and don't have
a context for it ethical and social and
so on you won't be able to help very
much because you could be a brilliant
scientist or mathematician or whatnot
but you will have no control over where
your discovery goes and I think that
that's why I'm so big on on Jesuit
education because for like 400 years
they just won't let you graduate without
that yeah at Santa Clara we have a core
curriculum which is about 20-some
percent of the overall coursework
regardless of what your major is so you
just cannot get out of that school
without writing properly without
thinking properly without taking a class
on ethics without some understanding of
other things and then when you're broad
like that then things could come easier
because all of these problems that we're
talking about a really complex you
cannot really solve them just looking at
it from one angle and you have to not
just be able to do it you have to enjoy
doing it exactly there's there's a lot
of fun in doing that yeah it's a you can
do one thing really well but eventually
it'll it'll get stale yeah and that's
part of the joy of discovery is to vary
things a little bit
yeah the multidisciplinary approach what
we celebrate with with one caveat the
multidisciplinary is wonderful but you
have to be well grounded in at least one
yeah you cannot be shallow across the
board you know that's the French have a
word for they call it dilettante
dilettante meaning you're basically
superficial in everything
yeah you don't know so you have to do it
from a position of strength and then
branch out mmm according to your mmm
liking but yeah so the back and that
that's actually why I teach the class
the way I teach it there has there's a
technical piece to it there their
projects there's an exam you actually
have to learn chaos theory before you
can have an opinion on chaos there yeah
because it's a it's a subtle thing
and if the easiest thing in the world is
to get the wrong interpretation
analogies are nice but analogies will
only take you so far it's the
introduction to the problem yeah the
real deal is is to understand what that
really means because when I tell you
something is infinitely sensitive you
won't think twice you'll take my word
for it
butterflies can do whatever they want
well not really
chaos theory not every system is chaotic
some are some are not and even if
they're capable of chaos there are
certain conditions that need to be in
place for that to happen and under other
conditions they'll behave like any other
system so understanding that gives you
the perspective to expand and that's why
I think that that scientific education
and this broader philosophical if you
will spiritual artistic education should
go hand in hand because separating
things is just a convenience actually
it's what's what the brain likes to do
to to minimize the blood flow basically
separate categories it's easier that way
it's metabolically speaking cheaper but
the real thing is to mix them up and I
thrive on that that's why I love
interdisciplinarity but from a position
of strength yeah you have to know
certain things really well first mmm-hmm
I love how you bring up the Jesuit
education that's so important
it's what why did we lose the polymath
why did we lose the the curriculum of at
least some philosophy and at least some
ethics and at least some some other
sorts of like speaking and and etiquette
and business and manners why this is a
dark villain it wants to control us
that's why Jesuits well it doesn't make
money in the short term so if you if you
want somebody to fit in perfectly into
and I think that paradigm might change
eventually but if you want if classes
being yeah born yeah yes because I think
what separates Silicon Valley from much
of the rest of the world is that
innovation piece and innovation it just
it doesn't fall into your lap you have
to it's it's there but you have to be
ready to do that and you know to connect
the dots you have to have enough dots
and they need to be sufficiently diverse
and then you'll think out of the box I
mean it's it's it's a phrase that
everybody uses thinking out of the box
but how do you do that you know to
connect things that other people didn't
connect there has to be a big spectrum
of things out there for you to connect
and I think eventually and I really hope
so that this educational model will
survive you know literacy survived in
the dark ages and monasteries I think
this broad renaissance spirit will
survive in pockets and then one day
it'll come back into its own because you
really need to know many things today to
be functional and you know moving
forward in the next 50 years it'll be
only more won't be less the world is
already really complicated because it's
now very connected 50 years ago you
could talk about local crises today
there are no local crises something
happens in Southeast Asia you're gonna
feel it somehow because the world has
changed and then how do you think about
that mmm I grew up in Europe we studied
only European history which which is a
mistake we knew virtually nothing about
the Far East for example just an immense
Indian we did such a little bit of world
yes through yeah yeah that's really
important because history repeats itself
in it never quite identically but yes
it's it's because history is a product
of the human nature exactly and that
hasn't changed in a couple thousand
years yeah yeah it's not gonna change
I'm happy that you're identifying the
importance of creativity and innovation
that this is a those sort of call them
Rube Goldberg moments Goldberg machine
this sort of complicated energetic
output of the body heart and mind out
into the world of something creative is
very unique it happens once right we
birthed simulation into the world it
happened once one birth of this project
and then other things like taking
clothes and folding t-shirts folding
t-shirt folding t-shirt that's a
repetitive task that's right in this in
the crosshairs of software yeah
thank you Eric Weinstein and so because
of that that is the essence of job
retraining mm-hmm get out of the
crosshairs of software well and get into
the Rube Goldberg moments so that way
you can birth out your book or your
video or your whatever your thing is and
into the world this idea and actually
build it and then the breath and some
depth of information in the way that we
see the world so there's there's this um
there's I just posted this and you
touched on this I wanted to mention it
the world is so complex that I spend as
much of my time possible learning mm-hmm
because I I can't I can't imagine what
my life would be like if I spent less
time learning because if I spend less
time reading and watching very smart
people in engaging with very smart
people and learning directly from them
thank you for that
did less of this we would learn less if
we learn less than we we leave ourselves
with less of an understanding of Geralt
and we need more of an understanding of
the world in order to actually help pass
that understanding down to other people
other kids I agree but that's hard
that's what I call an unstable
equilibria you have in my world of
control systems you have two kinds of
equilibria one is like the bottom of a
hole you don't have to do anything
you're gonna fall in there on your own
the other one is on top of a hill you
have a heck of a view from there but
you're fragile the tiniest thing can so
what you're suggesting is living on top
of that hill people don't like to do
that they fight wars rather than change
their mind you read a book today to this
day but mark that right there but it's
true
that's the definition of fanaticism if
you will because you're fanatically
defending a set of beliefs that you
don't want to not change necessarily but
just a question I I could tell you for
if I was I teach my class in India among
other places and in Calcutta they took
me once to the place where mother Teresa
worked and I had a chance to speak to
one of the nuns who lived with her
actually she shared a room with her so I
asked her among other things okay well
did she ever have doubts given the
horrific place where she worked I said
yes every day every day every day but
her faith would prevail yeah so it's not
about eliminating doubts
it's about prevailing over them exactly
and those are - and those who fight the
wars don't question those things they
don't have doubts they don't even get to
that phase and then you know you're
looking at somebody who has been a role
model certainly of the 20th century like
Mother Teresa and believe me if you go
to that place you will understand why
it's a horrific place and the fact that
she spent decades there it's you have to
ask the question how can somebody even
do that yes let alone voluntarily do and
that's the answer so it's a question
of a question of debating it with
yourself and others all the time that's
that's a full-time job that's why I say
it's on top of a hill because you can't
stop if you stop you'll slowly roll down
and you will find your little
equilibrium and you won't care about the
rest of the world and then then you can
live in your little bubble I really like
that there's the there's this crevice
that you fit into this hole Oh
I mean think of it this way just a
little a hole where you go up the wall
and you go back down yeah or yeah
correct or at the peak you exactly so
that's unstable versus stable exactly
yeah and this the stable is you think we
can we can say steeped in ignorance yeah
and so when when we're when we're here
it's very it's appealing it's easy it's
appealing it's easy it's how can we be
so satisfied with knowing that we know
so little that's where the
dunning-kruger effect comes in because
we're down here but we think that we
know a lot and so that we don't hustle
but when we get here when we're very
unstable we because we're learning more
and more about the earth and about
humanity and the social fabric in the in
the intellectual fabric and the
technological fabric we're all the way
up here in from up here we realize that
we know nothing and then at any point if
we're you know doing something and then
we get bumped off it's really you know
what's steep you got a really hustle to
get back up when you get bumped off like
that I've been bumped off so many times
okay that's that's the 15 minute mark
45 we're at 45 yeah 15 left all right
putting our hourglass on the table Wow
oh my gosh but without it Alex how did
we do that how did we get through no way
that was so fast oh my gosh time flies
you but when you think about what you
just said all the great ones like
Einstein Heisenberg all of these guys
had a sense of humility because they
knew so much yes they touched kind of
the outer limits of knowledge and it's
the mediocrities that are that are the
highliners they're the ones worn
the ones who have no questions anymore
everything is set did you know that in
1890 the German Patent Office was almost
closed because they claimed there was
nothing more to find out oh this was
right there hubris around 1890 yep and
right around that time quantum mechanics
and relativity theory changed physics
but it was truly the perception that you
know we've nailed it all Newton's laws
prevail thermodynamics is in charge
we've sold it off so just the
recognition that that'll never happen is
a first step and and and then the next
step is to enjoy that because I used to
be my technical areas control theory
right enjoy that it's totally cool it's
so funny to even have the hubris to say
oh we know everything close the Patent
Office but then you say that we know we
know we will never know everything so
because of that let's be cool with
whatever and that is the beginning of
every religious tradition if you will
that humility to accept the fact that
there is a mystery mm-hmm there are
certain things that and and secondly
that that it's a good thing because if
you lived in a Newtonian universe I
think you'd blow your brains out because
I'd be the most boring predictable
universe imaginable this one I mean
predictable oh it could be for the good
or bad but at least there's hope you
know you have no idea what will happen
and that's that's I think what makes us
human as well the possibility to to
engage that thing I want to I want to
ask you about this as we come on our on
our way out how about the importance of
starting with science with an education
for children we have a parent that's
kind of this deity for the child once
they're born into the world we have this
community we have these teachers we
don't have this objective book of
reality that we pass to the child we
don't say that your heart beats about a
hundred thousand times a day the
molecular composition of water is this
the gravity is this ten plus two is four
right we don't really give them this
this objective book at a young age we
don't
parents give it to them yeah why don't
we start with that platform well I think
schools do kind of kind of but it's not
reinforced yeah society doesn't really
yes that's where the real reinforcement
needs to happen through through media
through whatever these kids listen to in
their spare time somebody tells you
science is cool like Carl Sagan did in
the old days and you know people like
that or even earlier when when the space
race was on it was cool to be a rocket
science yes you know nowadays it's cool
to make money it was always cool to make
money but now it's particularly cool to
make money in tow in a sports car and I
can see wash and and then what you know
yeah because that's what I think
Schopenhauer said that that at the end
of this you can only escalate escalate
escalate at the end of that lies boredom
yep there's a famous story about Tolstoy
who who at the time was the greatest
writer of his age he was super Richard a
Russian count he could apparently write
a week on his estate and not reach the
end he at one point contemplated suicide
for about two years he didn't know what
to do with himself because he could
accomplished everything because if you
don't have this additional spiritual
peace yeah if you're only in the
material world and success and all that
it'll come to a point where you will
saturate and then what so you see people
at a certain point in their career look
to philanthropy to things like that
that's it's that instinct what next and
it's been so much better if you start
out with it then to find that out at the
at the end of yeah yes which is the
teaching process the children be that we
are using money as a tool for us to
achieve our ideas and our goals in life
we're just using as a tool on the way
yes that the materialistic possessions
will not bring you happiness but
providing value to the world don't bring
you happiness and we will provide these
great experiences of being alive to
other people as in like it cost money
too
yeah maybe go skiing or two or two you
lose some thrilling activities and stuff
but we will provide those for everyone
that when they want to do it but really
providing value for people first and
foremost is this crucial pillar because
money you can lose but the one thing
nobody can take away from you are your
experiences I this to you I've spent an
ungodly amount of money on travel for
the last 20-some years with my wife and
my kids and that for somebody is money
gone but the experiences just experience
the world the world is a beautiful place
yes and I saw this with my kids I think
it's also transformational it's so
transparent when they went to Japan for
the first time they saw a place that
works in a totally different way yeah
perfectly yeah and then that tells you
well if there are many ways to do this
yes and immediately you're inoculated
against these kind of monolithic
theories there's one and only one way to
do things no yes there are many ways to
do things and and to this day they you
know they will go to Japan any time and
so well I I mean it because it's a truly
aesthetic culture yeah it's a special
place yes they pay attention to
everything and and we cannot emulate
that but the recognition that something
like that is possible is a first step
for us to change the way we can yeah as
a society and and we can I think you
measure a society not by what it is at a
certain point in time but what it could
be
yeah and we have the resources to be
anything this is the richest country on
earth where we really shouldn't have
poverty at all where certain things
should be acknowledged as human rights I
mean when you and you look at what the
founding fathers said with the pursuit
of happiness to me that means quality
education that means health care so how
can you be fully happy if you have to
worry about those things whole day all
the time
yeah yeah and they were all of them
Jefferson in particular but all of them
were really followers of the
Enlightenment they're a product of the
Enlightenment they really put into
practice with the French Revolution
theorized about
and we're kind of forgetting that we're
also fiying that segment what pursuit of
happiness does not necessarily just
reduce to money it reduces to other
things and we should we should be aware
of that and that's why I think this
system of education is the key to how we
do that we can't agree on a curriculum
that's universal
for the entire country we cannot agree
on on three great books that everybody
has to read you cannot democratize
education to that point not that early I
think maybe I'm kind of a product of a
bygone era but a little bit of
dictatorship in education is good and
then you kind of earn your stripes and
yeah yeah exactly I tell my students the
sophomores that democracy stops at that
door by the time they're seniors and
take that science in religion class we
talk but not not at the beginning
because they need to learn a few things
and that's not negotiable yeah yeah
exactly and but if that's the truth then
that that democracy stops at the door
well in my classroom but but I think
that that same thing applies to really
to anyone that's trying to profess
something to teach it to other people
because if you're coming into a pedagogy
and you're coming in you're totally
welcome to be skeptical but if you're
coming in you got to give it your all
especially from a very young age and
learn about these basic fundamental
objective truths and move forward in the
world
you bring up going and traveling with
your family you gave your children one
of the best gifts a parent can give
their kids and myself in the process
yourself in the process which is
literally taking their minds and saying
look the way that these humans work over
on this part of the globe is different
than the way they work over here but
it's also similar in some ways but to be
able to see that on different parts of
the earth shows you that there are
different ways to live I was thinking
about a little child being raised on
Market Street in San Francisco and I was
just thinking about what it would be
like to have lived on Market Street for
like twenty years or something and see
like hyper techies hyper homeless I
protect you so poor homeless and then
you know you maybe go to Tokyo and then
you're like there are no homeless
there's no and then
and everything's so aesthetic on-time
fast beautiful it's like the real place
is Kyoto Kyoto yeah I mean I like Tokyo
too but Kyoto if you want the ultimate
is that yeah that's something else and
so so okay as we come to close let's
let's see let's make sure we've had as
much as we can yeah we've had we've had
as much as we can I think let's let's
ask you a couple questions do you have
do you have a point about what we've
been talking about that you wanna that
comes to mind that you think is really
important to address about what you've
been learning and about something
important to take home I want to I'm
going to ask you a couple of these
simulation questions in what regard
like one of these like something really
important from your research from your
studies and from what you've been
teaching I think some humility - I don't
think what I'm currently thinking is the
end of the line yeah I think it'll
change yes and it'll change as I learn
more and there's no end to that and I
think the the part that I learned over
the years is to enjoy the process
because it used to frustrate the hell
out of me I when I first heard of
girdles theorem which really undermines
math and makes it imperfect I was
actually I'm quite unhappy about it and
as a while this this was my perfectly
built universe and all of a sudden you
know math has issues
yeah but eventually you you turn that on
its head and you you start finding
beauty in that and yeah and this the the
fact that reality will surprise you all
the time
becomes a good thing because it could go
either way good or bad but it's not
predictable and predictability is what
kills us because there's no hope there's
no room for the proper change surprise
prefer every every form of beauty is
somehow related to surprise yeah
something new - yeah slightly different
slightly different and beauty is iiiii
harp on beauty because that's universal
to humans I mean as much as I've
traveled almost every place has
a certain aesthetic that we can
understand although we may be totally
different from that culture yes because
we at the end of the day we're all human
and have the same modes of perception so
certain things resonate regardless of
how much you know about a culture that's
that first impression now if you want to
go deeper then you have to learn about
what that thing means or some but just
the visual piece I never I never get
enough of that because yeah as I said
the world is a beautiful place
if you keep your eyes open yeah and
there's this this thing that I learned
from a Jesuit friends they call it the
sacrament of the present moment the
present is the only reality that you
have access to yeah and we often ignore
that and constantly anticipate or think
about the past yes and beauty is what
plugs you in to the present because it's
there you cannot avoid it it's it's your
most direct contact with the present
moment and I think therefore with
whatever greater reality is out there
that's why I yes push it so hard the
full energetic immersion in the now
every cell and ability of your body to
perceive into the moment yes yes in when
we pure spirit moment with all of that
mind heart soul everything no moment
after moment we will find endless yeah
abundance and you know in breath and in
being alive and hopefully we have our
basic water food shelter yeah it said
you're met but every mystical tradition
will tell you that same thing all of
those who experience that talked about
this timeless moment yes and even
Einstein's theory allows for something
like that there's a if you were able to
move at the speed of light time would
stop for you yeah yeah we can't because
we have no zero mass so our mass would
blow up to infinity but theoretically
such a reference point exists and maybe
you can plug into it in different ways
through art through information through
yeah information is something that we
don't understand very well yet but it
has its laws and
rolls and I mean there's a there's an
interesting book let's let's let's uh I
want to I want to make sure we get to
these questions sure what's so I want it
I want to ask this one especially
because you brought up humility humility
is so important what do you think is the
deepest emotion you've ever felt
I think love that's that's the universal
standard for all human beings but and
and there's a difference between love
and infatuation
I think infatuation is a hormonal thing
it happens comes and goes
real love is hard work and that's why I
think family is important in things and
friends and that that's usually not a
smooth process and that too is something
you would like to kind of idealize but
reality won't allow that because we all
have different personalities it's easy
to love someone from a distance oh yeah
a little harder if you share you know
living quarters but and that's the real
test but at the end of the day you know
if you manage to experience or perhaps
provide unconditional love which we tend
to do to our kids that's something how
about all right so we're out of time so
I have to go quick with these what do
you think we're alone in the cosmos in
meaning as an intelligent species I
can't say I mean statistically it
doesn't have to be so the question for
us is are we the only child or not would
that really matter to you or do we have
siblings I like that phrase but the
point is there's there should be a
parent to all there should be a parent
all yeah what and what is that parent
yes well that's four that's a question
for the ages but that's where we're all
the the great spiritual traditions begin
do we errants care cosmic siblings I
like I like that way
cosmic sibling or would we even know how
to find them how do we find our cosmic
siblings because we think in terms of
our
carl sagan i don't know if you read
cosmos it was a movie afterwards also
where he assumed that we would at least
agree on math which is not a given yeah
they could have a different math because
our math is as a product of the way the
human brain processes certain things
axioms are not a must that's just how we
like to organize information but and
given those axioms math as we know it
follows but who knows you know some
other galaxy what that would look like
you you think that some of our cosmic
siblings are advanced enough to have
simulated the universe that we live I
have no idea I'm not that big on science
fiction I'm perfectly happy with the
fact that that through us the universe
is self-aware maybe its self-aware in
other ways yeah but we have proof of
concept so to speak yes and that is
something given where we started we
started with a particle soup and now we
have discovered black holes and the
Higgs boson and God knows what else we
will discover yes let me see if I can
pull one out what do you think about how
do we work together with them the
proliferation of artificial intelligence
and often equality how what do you think
foresee that well artificial
intelligence in my mind will always have
that attribute artificial to it because
I think part what one has to understand
is that intelligence is not just
algorithmic thought or rational thought
our thought process involves three
things reason the unconscious mind and
the emotions and only those three
together are what we call human
intelligence if you take just one piece
the algorithmic piece it will be
artificial and therefore limited in
scope when you look at how Einstein and
Einstein was very candid about this how
his ideas came up he said that they all
came up for the unconscious mind it kind
of bubbled up to the surface and his
gift was to grab it the moment it does
because it's it's a fleeting phenomena
fleeting phenomena that's why I always
try and write exactly I know he was very
good at canis
looping it up we have no algorithm to
explain how that part of the mind works
it's questionable whether it's even
describable as an algorithm because we
know the certain things are not
describable algorithmically so mmm so we
have to figure out how to describe it's
not possible that's the thing it might I
think I think it might not be but I do
think it it is because if the way that a
car is currently perceiving its
environment is is already available to
us then what about seeing if there's a
potential way to to compute creativity
which is what Maya does so you can
certainly do things with that but I
would never equate it to human
creativity because there's a level
beyond which all of this stuff is
programmed somebody had to think of a
kind of framework within which that
would emerge now that is ultimately a
human product you're looking at
something much deeper I don't know if
you're familiar with Young's analogy of
the mind as an iceberg mm-hmm where you
have an iceberg that sits in the ocean
and the part that's above is is the
conscious mind then you have the
unconscious then you have the collective
unconscious which is the ocean in which
it floats if that exists what is that
ocean yeah and how on earth do you turn
that into an algorithm you know that's
that that's where I can dove
philosophically draw the line now I
think we have to think through the
consequences of artificial intelligence
of the kind that we can produce because
that'll cost jobs for attitude and and
that will create an upheaval of I think
of a magnitude that we have not
experienced correct before correct
white-collar jobs are going to go yeah
and then what yeah and we should think
along the lines of what Norway has done
Norway basically said okay when that
happens there will be a lot of excess
money who gets that money if a small
percentage gets that money then
everybody else gets thrown under the bus
if we share that money that's created
through this then yeah
there may be fewer jobs but some of that
money will help these people bridge the
gap and I think that's how we have to
think and retrain for new work yes there
will be new work yeah these fields there
will be new work but a lot and a lot
more will go a lot more will go so you
have to think about that discrepancy
yeah and how do we make sure that the
social fabric doesn't get so disrupted
that we have a revolution or a war yes
yeah because if you cross that critical
boundary that that's the danger yeah I
got nothing to say we got we're out of
time but I mean I mean I do but yeah
Ronald's got a lot to say he's gonna die
you know you talked about humility
earlier we have to embrace death as life
and just I hate to say it but you know
live and let die speaking words of
wisdom Paul McCartney says let it be
mother Mary comfort me I don't know what
to tell you but we have to look at death
as not an end all as part of life and we
have to understand that we have we're
7.5 billion but we need to get to 500
million and keep it there and I don't
know how to get there well I you're
right yeah nobody nobody but us are
taking away jobs you know the the
immigrants aren't coming for your jobs
it's just us it's our evolutionary
process and and I can't say any more
because I'll volunteer you know that
I'll be the first one to say hey I'm
useless human being I had a good time
let me go first I'm happy that we're
starting to unpack this at the end this
is a whole nother episode of
conversation you know you bring up the
point of education through our own
conversation and you know we care about
that a lot how do we get children to
understand the age that we're about to
enter and how to get out and train
properly and how do we make sure that
social fabric exists you foster their
actualization but also to foster collect
prospering everybody prospering so that
we had interdisciplinary aesthetics with
symmetry and asymmetry we talked about
the religion and science we talked about
chaos and order we talked about quantum
mechanics and string theory we talked
about quantum entanglement we talked
about we talked about so many things
Polymathic education of them no politics
imagine that and no politics
imagine that we didn't even touch on
politics this whole conversation
deliberately deliberately so definitely
keep that in mind as you think about
what just happened there was zero
references to any political conversation
and we had very good thought-provoking
conversation about society about history
about where we're going all that stuff
so so keep that in mind as we move
forward in the world it's that we can
have really great conversations that are
not about CNN verse Fox News absolutely
in that polarization okay so you have
some books coming out so we'll you know
we'll get those links in the bio once
they're available we'll throw them in
there we'll put the link to the current
book from 2012 in the Bible for people
to check out Alex we hope to have you on
the show
pleasure again soon this was so much fun
it was you have a good time wonderful
good yeah let's do it again sue cuz we
have so much to unpack but is there call
as well these are great questions yeah
well we have so much more I like your
mind is really great for the show you
you know you have a good day you have
the breadth and depth that's very
important to have guys thank you for
tuning in share this content we need you
to share it okay share with other people
get them inspired get them thinking
these about these in multivariate and
important questions to talk to other
humans about subscribe hit that
subscribe button join us comment below
with your thoughts give us a like
join us on patreon and we need help we
need help supporting the studio or
electricity our rent our internet or
food we need to grow the team we need to
make more video clips we need to do all
this stuff we need to we need to really
do it patreon.com for / simulation
series thank you Ron Vargas art
producing partner thank you everyone for
tuning in and we'll see
[Music]
[Music]